Albert Camus was an extremely handsome,
mid 20th century French Algerian philosopher and writer
whose claim to our attention is
based on three novels:
The Outsider, The Plage,  The Fall and
two philosophical essays:
The Myth of Sisyphus and The Rebel.
Camus won the Nobel Prize for Literature in 1957
and died at the age of 46, inadvertently
killed by his publisher Michelle Gallimard
when his Facel Vega sports car they
were in crashed into a tree.
In his pocket was a train ticket he had
decided not to use last-minute.
Camus' fame began with and
still largely rests upon his novel of 1942:
The Outsider.
Set in Camus' native Algiers,
it follows the story of a laconic
detached ironic hero called Meursault.
A man who can't see the point of love or work or friendship,
and who one day, somewhat by mistake,
shoots dead an Arab man
without knowing his own motivations and
ends up being put to death
partly because he doesn't show any
remorse but not really caring for his
fate one way or the other.
The novel captures the state of mind,
defined by the sociologist Emile Durkheim, as
"Anomie,"
a listless, affectless, alienated condition where one feels entirely cut off from others
and can't find a way to share their
sympathies or values.
Reading The Outsider has long been a well-known
adolescent rite of passage among french
and many other teenagers,
which isn't a way of doing it down for a
lot of the greatest themes
are first tackled at 17 or so.
the hero of The Outsider, Meursault,
cannot accept any of the standard answers
for why things are the way they are.
He sees hypocrisy and sentimentality
everywhere and can't overlook it.
He's a man who can't accept the normal
explanations
given to explain things like the
education system, the workplace,
relationships or the mechanism of government
He stands
outside normal bourgeois life
highly critical of its pinched morality
and narrow concerns for money and family.
As Camus put it in an afterword he
wrote for the American edition of the book:
"Meursault doesn't play the game. He refuses to lie..."
"...he says what he is, he refuses to hide
his feelings..."
"...and so society immediately feels
threatened."
Much of the unusual mesmerizing quality
of the book comes from the coolly
distant voice in which Meursault speaks to us, his readers.
The opening is one of the most legendary in
twentieth-century literature, and sets the tone.
"Aujourd’hui, maman est morte.
Ou peut-être hier, je ne sais pas."
The ending
is a stark and is defiant.
Meursault condemned to death for a murder
committed almost off hand,
because it could be interesting to know
what it's like to press the trigger,
rejects all consolations and heroically
accepts the universe's total
indifference to human kind.
"My last wish was that there should be a
crowd of spectators at my execution..."
"...and that they should greet me with
cries of hatred."
Even if we're not killers, and we'll ourselves
be really quite sad when our mother dies,
the mood of The Outsider is one we're
all liable to have some experience of.
When we have enough freedom to realize
we are in a cage but
not quite enough freedom to escape it.
When no one seems to understand and
everything appears a little hopeless,
perhaps in the summer before we go to college.
Aside from The Outsider, Camus' fame
rests on an essay published the same
year as the novel
called The Myth of Sisyphus.
This book, too, has a bold beginning:
"There is but one truly serious
philosophical problem..."
"...and that is suicide."
"Judging whether life is or is not worth living,"
"...that is the fundamental
question of philosophy."
The reason for this stark choice is
in Camus' eyes because
as soon as we start to think
seriously, as philosophers do,
we will see that life has no meaning and
therefore we will be compelled to wonder
whether or not we should just be done
with it all.
To make sense of this rather
extreme claim and thesis,
we have to situate Camus in the
history of thought, his dramatic
announcement that we have to consider
killing ourselves because
life might be meaningless, is premised on
a previous notion
that life could actually be rich in
god-given meaning.
The concept which will sound remote to
many of us today
and yet we have to bear in mind that for
the last two thousand years in the West
a sense that life was meaningful
was a given,
accorded by one institution above any other -
The Christian Church.
Camus stands in a long line of
thinkers, from Kierkegaard
to Nietzsche,
to Heidegger and Sartre
who wrestle with a chilling realization
that there is in fact no preordained
meaning in life.
We're just biological matter spinning
senselessly on a tiny rock,
in a corner of an indifferent universe.
We were not put here by a benevolent deity
and asked to work toward salvation in the
shape of the Ten Commandments,
there's no roadmap and no bigger point and,
it's this realization that lies at the heart
of so many of the crises reported by
the thinkers we now know
as the existentialists.
A child of despairing modernity,
Albert Camus accepts that all our
lives are absurd in the grander scheme
but, unlike some philosophers, he ends up
resisting utter hopelessness or Nihilism.
He argues that we have to live with the
knowledge that our efforts will be
largely futile,
our lives soon forgotten, and our species
irredeemably corrupt and violent
and yet we should endure nevertheless.
We are like Sisyphus,
the Greek figure ordained by the Gods
to roll a boulder up a mountain,
and to watch it fall back down again in
perpetuity.
But ultimatelly, Camus suggests we
should cope as well as we can
at whatever we have to do, we have to acknowledge
the absurd background to existence,
and then triumph of the constant
possibility of hopelessness.
In his famous formulation
"One must imagine Sisyphus happy."
This brings us to the most charming
and seductive side of Camus,
the Camus wants to remind himself
and us of the reasons why life can be
worth enduring,
and who in the process writes with
exceptional intensity and wisdom
about relationships, nature, the summer,
food, and friendship.
As a guide to the reasons to live,
Camus is delightful.
Many philosophers have been ugly and cut
off from their bodies,
think of sickly Pascal,
crippled Leopardi,
sexually unsuccessful Schopenhauer or
poor peculiar Nietzsche.
Camus was by contrast very
good-looking, extremely successful with
women for the last ten years of his life,
he never had fewer than three
girlfriends on the go, and wives as well
and had a great dress sense, influenced
by James Deen and Humphrey Bogart
It isn't surprising that he was asked to
pose by American Vogue.
These weren't all just sylistic quirks, once
you properly realize that life is absurd
you're on the verge of despair perhaps,
but also compelled to live life more
intensely.
Accordingly Came grew committed to
and deeply serious about the pleasures
of ordinary life.
He said he saw his philosophy as
"A lucid invitation to live and to create
in the very midst of the desert."
He was a great champion of the ordinary
which generally has a hard time finding
champions in philosophy
and after pages and pages of his dense
philosophy, one turns with relief to
moments when Camus writes with
simplicity in praise of sunshine, kissing
or dancing.
He was an outstanding athlete as a young
man, once asked by his friend Charles Poncet
which he preferred, football or the
theater.
Camus is set to have replied:
"Football, without hesitation."
Camus played as goalkeeper for the
junior local Algiers team
Racing Universitaire de Algier, which won
both the North African Champions Cup
and the North African Cup in the
1930's.
The sense of teamspirit fraternity and common purpose,
appeal to Camus enormously.
When he was asked in the 1950s
by a sportsmagazine
for a few words regarding his time with
football, he said:
"After many years during which I saw many things..."
"what I know most surely about morality
and the duty of man..."
"I owe to sport."
Camus was also great advocate of the Sun,
his beautiful essay Summer in Algiers
celebrates the warmth of the water and the
brown bodies of women.
He writes "For the first time in two
thousand years the body has appeared
naked on beaches,
for twenty centuries men have striven to
give decency to Greek
insolence a naiveity to diminish the
flesh and complicate dress
but today young men running on
Mediterranean beaches
repeat the gestures of the athletes
of Delos." He spoke up for a new
paganism, based on the immediate
pleasures of the body.
This extract from Summer in Algiers:
"I recall a magnificent, tall girl who
danced all afternoon. She was wearing a
jasmine garland on her tight blue dress
wet with perspiration from the small of
her back to her legs
she was laughing as she danced and
throwing back her head
as she passed the tables she left behind
her a mingle scent of flowers and flesh."
Camus railed against those who would
dismiss such things as trivial and longed
for something higher, better, purer.
"If there is a sin against this life..."
he wrote,
"it consists perhaps not so much into sparing of life,"
"as in hoping for another life and eluding
the quiet grandeur of this one."
In a letter he remarked:
"People attract me insofar as they are impassioned
about life and avid for happiness..."
"There are
causes worth dying for, but none worth killing for."
Camus achieved huge acclaim in his
lifetime, but the Parisian intellectual
community was deeply suspicious of him.
He never was a Parisian sophisticate,
he was a working-class Pied-Noir,
that is someone born in Algeria but of
European origin,
whose father had died of war-wounds when he was
an infant, and whose mother was a cleaning lady.
It isn't a coincidence that Camus'
favorite philosopher was Montaigne,
another very down to earth frenchmen,
and someone one can love as much for
what he wrote, as for what he was like.
Someone one would have wanted as a
wise and a life-enhancing friend.
This, too, is what philosophy is about.